voici la maison de la famille Guenin et
voici celle de la famille Tessier au
milieu pour les séparer une palissade de
7 mètres de haut depuis 4 ans époque où
les guenins sont venus s'installer à
côté de chez les Tessier les deux
familles sevouent une haine féroce à
l'origine de leurs différences une
banane à l'histoire de limite de terrain
qui s'étant venimée à tel point qu'il y
a 2 ans l'été si entériés un mur de tôle
métallique pour ne plus voir les gunens
peine perdus les deux familles passent
leur temps à se provoquer en se jetant
des pires par-dessus le mur au début
cette version moderne des Horaces et des
Curiaces amusaient les habitants du
voisinage qui le dimanche venait jeter
un coup d'oeil sur le mur de la honte
comme il l'appelle aujourd'hui tout le
monde trouve que les plaisanteries les
plus courtes sont les meilleures et on
aimerait bien que cela cesse mardi soir
le différent entre les tessiers et les
guenins s'est réglé à coups de barre de
fer match nul monsieur Tessier et Madame
Guenin sont en arrêt maladie avec chacun
un doigt cassé et de multiples
ecchymoses quant à Monsieur Gonin et
Madame Tessier qui étaient jusqu'à
présent séparé par des tôles ils sont
actuellement en réuni derrière les
barreaux ils ont été placés en garde à
vue